whereby I have to turn here oh my god
why do you always find it because my
said you kiss at me late well this is
Google Maps then you need a snobby suit
Google Maps it sucks you stop spitting
yourself first
you know what's become a hell of a
second torpedo [ __ ]
I didn't see they are oh my god mark
going this way though what does that do
with my car yeah the loaner car was
going the Toyota the toy that is going
this way you talk about the one that's
going this way on the opposite end of
the road
yeah but the roads not that way it's
perfectly fine and we know it's you
driving so we thought you're gonna go oh
wow look [ __ ] both of you yeah there's
there's a head it's they're mad yeah
I've seen you were in the bar no they
should have seen the car coming and they
backed out anyways so you guys are
worried about a car that's on the other
side of the road that makes no sense at
all whatsoever
again there is you are in your [ __ ]
face you know why the [ __ ] this camera
will turn the [ __ ] off Ardell [ __ ] yeah
right that kind of a guy cries yeah I
like how you guys are just pointing
normal [ __ ] out and making it seem like
it's some big deal you see a person all
the way across the other [ __ ] Street
is about to walk across straight right
now
stupid you shouldn't question why don't
be a freshly cut lawn I don't poet it
out to you did you do that huh you like
it racist it's not racist can you open
your eyes I look out your two front
teeth oh you should do it because the
gap needs to be bigger anyways I don't
give up no the gaps on the bottom no
everyone you really I know your teeth go
like that see what you always do she
always tries to pick something to make
me feel really any words every time I'm
gonna do that to you too what was the
other thing I told you that you started
bleeding I did a little bit cross-eyed
or what was it I actually I'm a little
cross-eyed though
I've seen it that's the one thing that
have you stared in the mirror gosh yes
face this video nation's [ __ ] do you
understand or you want me to start me
from the top and work myself to the
bottom you [ __ ] no are you flirting this
disgusting [ __ ] [ __ ] I will kill you
right now
don't ever do that I'm married that's
disgusting I told her that we are not
friends
you were like you were hanging out with
her and you're like don't misunderstand
this dynamic right now I'm not trying to
be your homeboy I'm trying to I'm trying
to make you my wife that's right I think
she was just so like taken aback because
she so used to you know the Korean guy
tactic there's a green detective it's
called the offbut tactic is where they
pretend to be your older woman I'm here
for you then because your shoulder here
cry here because Jesus will always love
you and so will I I'm here to be your
supportive brother you [ __ ] [ __ ] but
really trying to get that puss-puss - oh
that's what they're trying to get and
it's the saddest thing on earth I always
see it you don't think girls are into
that let me know girls art and they
always they can get the advice to
somebody else but they can't see it for
themselves
it's insane my girls like that because I
think it's just that comforting note say
listen I'm here for you
I'm here I'm your brother in Christ no I
[ __ ] you I'm here for myself yeah but
you're in addition push push and then
you're different though you're different
though you married a beautiful man
no way do you want me to hook you guys
up like what the hell this whole time at
all you talk about
I can't give you compliments I feel like
you you love him I do like romantically
that is none of your business I mean oh
my lord there's no car behind me Dania I
think you just need a drive every single
time really cuz she got to a multiple
car accident already like she's any
better source than I am
they weren't her fault they're never
ever fall would you stop
you're you're chill never gonna hate you
by the way what oh my God look at this
traffic why my kids gonna hate me
because doing to me don't do that wait
stop brake pause pause pause but [ __ ]
mom [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] wanna drive
anymore
and the bars gonna be the bag listen
your mom dinner
see no one I thought you into fitness or
anybody in that um I was until before he
got me into weight training but mom I
feel sad as hell before some minute yeah
I was really fat you must be so proud of
me right now not so much me now I played
sports and stuff I danced so I was
always pretty active yeah what did you
do David what did I [ __ ] do not bang
cuz that's what I did son Danny when I
was in choir oh yeah I was in choir oh
can you get them a little sample please
no do it what it what anyway anything
anything simple and it will ask me for
five seconds twinkle twinkle little star
how I wonder what you are
all right twinkle twinkle little star
number five you will stop [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're the star [ __ ] each other your
hands off the wheel we do an auto pilot
and we're a band [ __ ]
I'll stop [ __ ] oh look we coming to my
father's when they're twinkle oh I'm
coming to you how turn on the sprinklers
I'm a wedge of [ __ ] ah I'm a pumpkin
[ __ ] then I'm gonna take my dick and
stick it in your [ __ ] all better to
partners okay why did I go over to the
tickle the little starts are raping some
it wasn't rape I just he was consensual
because she was more attracted to me
than the other guy oh it sounded
aggressive and it sounded like a turtle
has to be aggressive no matter what oh
that's why I couldn't be a rapper give
me the love a non aggressive aggressive
love song oh it will start off baby
what's your name baby what's your son if
you don't love me then baby eat this not
down all up in the back of your [ __ ]
head oh [ __ ] that's because you
oh no right ahead with head oh that's
how rap is I'm gonna shoot you in the
head cuz you didn't give me head but
when you're behind you're not ahead yeah
that doesn't make any sense
go give another one use a piece of [ __ ]
you ain't [ __ ] with my [ __ ] cuz I'm
on a different level and I'm like [ __ ]
you piece of [ __ ] Wow t-rex I use words
then just they don't it doesn't work do
it alright obviously you hungry younger
cuz you like I'm hungry oppresses my
tree oh I'm hungry but I can't eat cuz I
just got a tongue ring oh uh uh oh y'all
bit of nose wrapper
oh my mind is blown right now you know
we started off with that twinkle twinkle
little bars you are driving without your
[ __ ] hands right now look show look
yeah what could we do on the test levy
style that's scary
no it's not it's really good on stopping
go chef well what I think happens too is
you panic and then you premature
ejaculate and you step on the brake
before you need to and then we're all
like cool yeah but I'd rather be safe
than sorry
alright well would lunch go [ __ ] your
neck I don't give a [ __ ] about session
by the head let's just snap off a roll
up like a [ __ ] dead pumpkin Oh yo
this neck is really tiny for this [ __ ]
it has to lug around all day all right
just take it easy with you what are you
talking about there's nothing in there
it's like a marble
can you focus on the pretend driving it
can you put on a show for people so you
don't make them freak out why what why
should I have to why should I have time
for that one special kiss but the buzzer
did better when the devil and T do that
to the time yeah he doesn't know
anything
maybe I saw get anywhere like this give
me something I wanna be a millionaire so
[ __ ] mad and I never had like you even
know like you he's like I love this song
Herman a job [ __ ] man or he'll make
some [ __ ] up that like is so morbid you
should have just been a singer dude man
if you me a singer you haven't even seen
yet learned how to sing dude you would
actually be attractive you mean whoa
what have a comp like a really strong
compliment
I don't know I feel about that yeah you
wouldn't help me I don't know where to
go again they actually look at you
opinion uh well there they come yes what
are you drunk magnet that's my bad and
what jazmine sullivan what's that oh oh
you don't know who Jasmine's oh I don't
know I bust a window Souchak oh oh
what other song besides that one if I
could forget home I would please believe
me
and I know that I should hold the telly
good evening
oh my god okay please look forward open
your eyes who do you do me no I want
look at you the whole time
Oh either break II just don't watch it's
gonna work see it knows that the car sir
Oh
[Applause]
you